right like you and eric you've done
three i think with eric yeah was your
four
yeah i haven't released the fourth year
okay so i i i watched all three uh
because i
i really thought your u way and him like
giving you advice is very interesting
dynamic i thought it was a very
interesting dynamic
um and i find him like a fascinating cat
we know
everybody in common except we've never
met it's very weird because you know you
you think about the social graph in the
real world this is why i think augmented
reality is going to be
such an amazing product i just have one
killer feature i want for augmented
reality
we wear our glasses and when i look at
you
above your head i see the relationships
we have
and the things we've done together yes
right so i see
oh you both know sam harris or you had
elon on the podcast
on this date or you and i were both at
burning man
in 2006 the most meaningful element of
our connection
network yeah and then because we would
discover that through small talk but
imagine you're like at a party
and you look and it just people glow
and you just see a glow around a person
and like green means you have some
financial relationship blue means you
have some friendship one yeah or yellow
means you have friendship one blue means
you know nothing about each other you
have no connections you're like wow
these blue people have no connection to
yeah these people that one's glowing red
we know seven or more people in common
yeah and those are the seven people oh
we should go talk about how we know each
other
yeah that could and that sort of
happened with facebook remember or
myspace where you were like oh you know
that person in front of a friend
yeah but that's what there's gonna be
ars like
this is why i think if apple figures out
ar
or snapchat and they just have those
glasses you know forget about vr
it's just nauseating and whatever but ar
where you put the glasses on you see the
real world but you augment it
well you make uh just like you were
saying you make it frictionless
a very low friction to make a deep human
connection because you you have all the
basic elements there already
now think about the unintended
consequences of what i just described
it could get creepy and weird the
privacy thing uh
i mean people will opt here's the thing
people
your privacy is an illusion like all
this information is there
and then people are more than willing to
give up privacy in exchange for
some value you know it's a value trade
yeah and giving if
if my tesla when i'm driving in the
direction of my house just starts the
navigation and saves me three clicks and
that friction is gone
i'm willing to give tesla my location
and my home address
right yes i'm not willing to give
zuckerberg anything i don't trust him
but
you get the idea i mean it would be that
way with like dna and other things at
some point we'll just be like yeah just
take my dna like i don't
yeah sure people can look and see that
i'm a mental and my iq is like
lower than i don't want to bring the
bell curve up or whatever but
but you could you could figure out like
if we all put our dna in the sequence
online and like oh yeah you know lex has
got 10 more iq points than j
cal and yeah you know sam's got 10 more
than lex and all of a sudden
people are like all bent out of shape
about it but what if they we did that
and they were like and by the way you
also all three of you are going to get
parkinson's unless you do x y and z
yeah unless you eat more blueberries or
whatever we figure out they're going to
accept it pretty quickly yeah that's
brave new world brave new world
you